joining us now trump campaign senior
adviser steve cortez steve as we
just reported in the latest fox poll
in the the overall horse race uh
biden leads trump by five points 51 to
46 but i want to drill down on some of
the internals
on key issues coronavirus law and order
and race
more voters trust the vice president
while mr trump
leads on the economy so far
the president has not broken through
steve well i think he is breaking
through on the most important issue
which is the economy you know there's a
lot of cross currents of course
in 2020 many things about this year are
unique and singular
but i still believe that the ultimate
driver of the electoral decision for
most americans is going to be what it
typically is who can create
prosperity for me for my family and for
this country going forward and on that
score
the president has a compelling story to
tell particularly given
the current economic renaissance that is
unfolding in this country this country
is coming back
with gusto right now all of the recent
economic data show that
this is the president who produced the
first trump boom and the american people
i believe will smartly rehire him to
continue to produce and compel the trump
boom 2.0
what about the fact that he trails biden
by a substantial margin
on the issue of who you trust more to
handle the coronavirus
look regarding coronavirus i think
here's the reality that i think
unfortunately corporate media has been
relatively successful
at pushing out a myth that the president
mishandled the virus and i actually when
i look at for instance
these revelations from woodward i think
if you look at them
in the context of the totality of
actions taken by this president
it actually reveals an exemplary record
of crisis management and what i mean by
that is it's very clear
that the president early on during the
fog of biological war
when the information coming in was
disparate and at times even
contradictory he made two determinations
number one
that he was going to reassure the
american people that he was going to be
the kind of leader who convinces the
people that we can persevere
through this epidemiological pearl
harbor but then secondly he also took
decisive action he made the command
decision to you to harness the full
power of the federal government to do
two things primarily he did a lot of
things but
the two main drivers to protect the
people were number one
he restricted travel first from china
then from europe eventually basically
effectively sealing the united states
border something that hadn't been done
this country
since 9 11. but then he also commenced
the largest government-mandated
manufacturing campaign in this country
since world war ii and the swiftness and
vastness with which the government
produced ppe
medical devices and also overflow
capacity
for hospital systems around this country
that ultimately wasn't needed thankfully
but was there nonetheless
uh that record i believe reveals a a
record of superb management actually of
the virus
well let's let you brought up the
woodward book and let's talk about the
president's
what you call superb management all of
these polls were conducted
at least in part before the public
learned the revelations from bob
woodward's book
which are essentially that the president
was saying something very
different and much more alarming to bob
woodward
in private than what he was telling the
public
take a look you just breathe the air and
that's how it's
uh passed uh it's also more deadly than
your
you know your even your strenuous flus
so
this is deadly stuff it's a little like
the regular flu that we
have flu shots for when you have 15
people
and the 15 within a couple of days is
going to be down to close to zero
uh that's a pretty good job we've done
so so he's telling bob woodward that
this is deadly stuff
and much worse in the flu in fact he
said five times worse than the flu
and in the public he's saying we're
going to be down to zero and it's no
worse than the flu
why not level with the american people
steve chris
here's what here's what's important we
have to look at the timeline there and
again this is this was the fog of war of
biological war
and the information was shifting the
medical experts in the sciences
i'm going to interrupt you steve i'm
going to interrupt you right there
because it wasn't the fog of war
on january 28 the president got a his
presidential daily brief the top
intelligence
uh in the oval office and at that point
his national security adviser robert
o'brien said this is the biggest
challenge
you're going to face in your entire
presidency and the deputy
national security adviser matthew
pottinger
immediately compared it to the spanish
flu the deadly spanish flu
of a hundred years ago so there was no
fog of war there the the word he was
getting from
his top intelligence and national
security people was that this was a
deadly pandemic there was no fog here
that no there was tremendous fog and let
me tell you why that was their view
you're exactly right
however dr fauci somebody who was
lionized by critics
of president trump somebody who clearly
is not looking to carry water for the
maga movement or is not a trump partisan
dr fauci
as late as february 29th he appeared on
national television on the today show
and said that no americans
should change their customs of life okay
so this was the fog of war
opinions and views and analyses were
shifting dramatically
among the scientists among the
politicians this entire time as we were
trying to learn
about the virus by the way dr fauci said
that and days later literally
he was advocating for a national
shutdown something that then happened
two weeks later in the middle of march
so i think it's unfair for you to
characterize things as if they were
solid
and unchanging these were shifting facts
shifting analyses and by the way part of
why we knew so little
is because the chinese communist party
who was the ultimate culprit in all of
this
not donald trump not the democrats no
american the chinese communist party
lied to the world they could have shared
the scientific and health information
with the world early on and in all
likelihood either contained this virus
to wuhan itself
or if it did get out of wuhan at least
helped the world to deal with it
effectively instead
we were searching largely in the
darkness to try to figure out the
scientific facts and again the
scientists themselves
were shifting their views dramatically
during this period
steve your explanation is somewhat
different from the president because
you're saying well the president didn't
really know
it was the fog of war but when he has
described it he said he didn't want to
panic
the country he didn't want to jump up
and down and panic the country
and one of the reasons that there's a
question about that
is because of the fact that the
president plays the panic card
all the time especially when he's
talking about joe biden
take a look if biden wins the mob
wins if biden wins the rioters anarchist
arsonists and flag burners win
peacefully protests
and peacefully protest
is that a president who is trying to
keep the country calm
there's a key difference here when the
president is talking about legitimate
fear of what can happen in america if
joe biden
were to win and if disrespect for the
police were to continue to become the
norm in this country
uh he is he is trying to exhort the
american people to action to say we can
stop this
we can back the police we can restore
order we can insist
on the rule of law that is sensible uh
to to uh
to recognize that there's legitimate
fear out there in the country what is
not helpful
would be to tell the american people
that this virus is out of control
because what would happen
things like hoarding which was happening
anyway at that time it was already
commencing
the president's job in a time of crisis
is partly to be reassuring to the
american people
to convince them that we can and will
persevere
through this epidemiological pearl
harbor and that's what he did he was
reassuring to the american people
at the same time he was taking decisive
action he didn't just offer flowery
phrases and then sit back
no he reassured the people and then okay
and steve i got it i i got your i got
your point
the the the argument would be that
there's a there's it's a false choice
you're making he either take plays a
rosy scenario
or he sets his hair on fire there is
something in the middle which is just
being honest with the american people
and there's a question steve as to
whether or not the president
is still being honest with the american
people i want to play what he and dr
fauci said this week about how long
the coronavirus is going to be with us
here they are
we're rounding the turn you see what's
happening you see the numbers are
plunging
if you're talking about getting back to
a degree of normality which resembles
where we were
prior to covid it's going to be well
into 2021
maybe even towards the end of 2021
those are very different messages we're
rounding the turn
versus the end of 2021 about how long
the virus is going to be with us
sure listen clearly the president has a
far more optimistic
view right now than does dr fauci but
let me also point out
even within the scientific community
there's tremendous debate for example
there's people like dr atlas from
stanford dr risch from yale a lot of
folks
within science who would disagree with
dr fauci the president is now making i
think very properly a really
optimistic case that we are nearing the
end of this that the trends are going
aggressively toward health and regarding
foul chief by the way because i think
this is critical
uh on this issue of supposed
discrepancies fauci on your network just
a few days ago
made it very clear that he doesn't
believe the president was being
dishonest let me be precise and quote
him he said this is dr fauci
talking about the president he said i
didn't see any discrepancies
what he told us what we told him and
what he came out
and said publicly and again nobody's
going to accuse dr fauci of being a
trump partisan
he said no discrepancies here
on in an interview on msnbc on friday he
said something different i find it
interesting that sometimes
you're citing him as an authority and
sometimes uh
you're you're saying he's wrong one last
question i've got only time for this on
the campaign
uh as we said no i just said the
president has a more optimistic view
i i didn't say fauci's wrong i'm just
saying the president has a more
optimistic view about the virus right
well well i mean but but
but dr fauci is the leading infectious
disease
expert in this country scott atlas who
you referred to isn't even an infectious
disease
expert he's a radiologist
there is a range of you within the
scientific community clearly by the way
the president's job though
is not to just rotately take the advice
only of scientists as if that is the
only input that matters
it's a critical input absolutely into
making policy but as are other
considerations for instance not just
physical health but also mental health
also the economic vitality of our
country national security
of inputs you're changing the subject
though we were talking about
the question of how long the virus is
going to be with us one last question
about the campaign and that has to do
with the issue of early mail-in voting
because at this point you seem to be
losing
that race and let me put up some numbers
in key swing states
florida and north carolina and
pennsylvania democrats lead republicans
by hundreds of thousands of requests for
mail ballots
in two of those three states by more
than two to one
between the president talking down
mail-in voting steve
and the fact that you've gone largely
dark in a lot of these states in terms
of tv ads
aren't just spotting the democrats a big
early lead
well i don't think so first of all too
we have not gone dark in overall
advertising we're doing a heck of a lot
of digital
advertising in those states but uh what
i would say regarding mail-in is look in
2016 we were losing the race until
election day and then won it big on
election day at least big electorally
and i i have the same view this time
around i think in all probability
we don't know for certain by the way a
lot of those democrats could be voting
for president trump
uh just because democrats request a
ballot doesn't mean they're voting for
biden but regardless
uh i would concede that it's probably
going to be a similar scenario where
when we look back respectively we will
probably see that the president was down
into election day and then won election
day itself by an incredibly wide margin
and i say that by the way largely
because of the enthusiasm gap which is
very real between our supporters
and joe bidens well and it's certainly
true
thousands of people showed up for that
rally in the middle of
basically nowhere in nevada last night
so
steve thank you thanks for joining us
always good to talk with you